we have a voicemail number. The number is
two one nine two David P [inaudible]. I find
today's voicemail really depressing because
there's a lot of stuff related to this going
on behind the scenes. Take a listen.
Hi David. Love your show. My name's Steve
from California, so I've been watching your
show. I'm on YouTube for a while now and I've
noticed that you have to consistently qualify
every statement you make with criticizing
the left or something similar. He Tulsi Gabbert
or Bernie Sanders or Elizabeth Warren or what
have you. And you said people send you irrational
messages or unsubscribe and get upset. So
my question is how do we solve this problem
of people not being able to have rational
conversations and listening to mild criticism
perhaps, or just different viewpoints. And
I think it's pretty outrageous that you have
to go to these lengths for your own audience.
It's really a kid that talking to children
and even in this case where the people writing
you likely largely agree with you. Yeah. So
just wondering what your take on that is,
but love the show and thanks.
Listen, I don't have the answer and I think
it's important to say this is a small percentage
of my audience, but it is allowed percentage
of my audience and yeah, I mean, listen, I
say Warren's leading the polls and I get absolutely
destroyed. I say Bernie is stronger on money
out of politics and I get absolutely destroyed
because I'm picking sides or whatever. You
know, I'm doing the best job I can to tell
you what the facts are and to interpret the
facts as best as I can. And so there's, there's
two ugly sides to this. There's the political
side, which is stuff like that. There's also,
you know, I mean people, I think one of the
criticisms of evangelicals who vote for Trump
is that they aspire claim to espouse certain
values and then they don't vote them. I don't
want to do that.
So one of the things that I do on this program
is as a business owner, I try to actually
live the values that I espoused. I think people
in the U S are overworked. They need more
vacation for example. So we take vacations
on the show, the staff gets time off. And
just the other day I got a message from someone,
I guess a leftist who said, I love what I
love the show love almost everything you say,
but you guys take too much time off and I'm
canceling my membership. I'm still gonna watch
this stuff but I'm not going to give you any
more money because I just don't think you
deserve it. I'm a business owner and I don't
take any vacation and I didn't write back
cause I'm not going to engage in this stuff.
But it is, you know, when I read that, I hear
that what, what the person is saying is I
need to have a better work life balance.
What kind of person would I be as someone
who politically is advocating a better, you
know, worker, uh, time off and resources and
better treatment of workers. If then I say
we're going to work through the year and we'll
have three days off at the end of the year,
right? I mean, he's like, we're not going
to do it, and if you're going to cancel your
membership for that or you gonna cancel your
membership, because I've reported polls, I
see it all as kind of part of the same problem
and unfortunately I do not know how to fix
it. I can only keep doing what I'm doing and
do it the best way I possibly can. We will
probably talk more about that and many other
things. On today's bonus show, the bonus show
is available to paid members and to patrons.
Paid members can sign up@joinpacmandotcompatronscansignupatpatrion.com
slash David Pakman show. We will talk about
a crackdown on fake statue of Liberty tours
after Alec Baldwin fell for the scam. We will
talk about the rise of virtual reality for
employment training and we will have a
truly horrible story about a Mexican Nayer,
uh, those stories and more on the bonus show.
Look forward to the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com
[inaudible].